like let me introduce myself I'm Raj Raj
Kumar
I'm I'll be the director of the Metro 21
smart cities Institute it turns out that
I am a professor in electrical Computer
Engineering in the College of
Engineering I also have appointments in
the robotics Institute in the school of
computer science and in the Heinz
College as well so the mission of the
metro 21 smart cities Institute is to
develop 21st century solutions the
challenges that face our metropolitan
region strain that's why the 21 comes
from some quick facts about the
Institute it turns out that the origins
of Metro 21 actually go back several
years now thanks to the pioneering ideas
from Dean Jim Garrett of the College of
Engineering and Dean Christian of the
Heinz College
I won't basically applaud them for yeah
early visionary ideas and then I guess
it took a more a formal step forward in
2014 where Metro 21 spun out of traffic
21 our successful transportation
Institute which also houses two USDOT
national university transportation
centers in this context I'd like to
acknowledge the many contributions and
leadership that Rick Stafford provided
the Zurich please stand apart a kebab
so without trick we would not be here I
could that can honestly say that
so Metro 21 is a university wide
Institute spans multiple colleges I'll
have more to say about that later the
backbone of Metro 21 is the broad and
deep partnership that we actually have
multiple entities out there including
governments the private sector and the
nonprofit sector so it's basically kind
of a nut shell thing for you to keep in
mind the founding sponsors which
basically really made it feasible are
the following as was cited by Grant
earlier the Henry Hillman Foundation
basically provided the religious seed
grants if you go with additional support
from Pentair and the IBM corporations
since then we have actually received
very generous contributions from the
Heinz endowments RK mellon Foundation
and the Bill foundation we want to
basically acknowledge their support
round of applause for the sponsor it
turns out that we actually have an
active member of understanding that
Karina clay highlighted with the mayor
we've been true partners we basically
deeply appreciate the partnership the
love and support shown by the city we
look forward to working with you as
long-standing partners for you you also
have a memory of understanding with the
county as well as you saw rich has been
a great supporter of activities here on
campus including traffic 21 and metro 21
we're in the process of coming up with
something similar with the airport as
well so so please stay tuned I will have
something to say in the near future so
Metro 21 how do you think about this
think of this basically as a as a
doorway that opens up all activities
related to smart cities at Carnegie
Mellon the College of Fine Arts
Diedra College of Humanities and Social
Sciences the College of Engineering the
Heinz College of information systems and
public policy the school of computer
science and the pepper School of
Business
this covers six of the seven colleges on
campus so you might be asking what
happened to the seven we are working on
it
the executive committee that basically
will guide that the affairs of the
Institute are the following
Bob daemon the Dean Tepper School of
Business Jim Garrett of course Dean
College of Engineering forum Shahani and
interim president Krishnan Dean of the
Heinz College Dan Martin Dean the
College of Fine Arts and room or the
Dean of the School of Computer Science
and Richard shyness from Dietrich
College of memories and social sciences
yeah I guess the next panel likely
you're many of them likely you'll hear
from and the Christian I believe
moderates that panel the two colors that
you see there Jim Garrett and Krishnan
are the deans of the College of
Engineering and the Heinz College will
be the governing deans if you go
given their early leadership a visionary
outlook that really actually helped this
initiative flourish and become a ninja
to you so thank you Jim and Thank You
Krishnan
so the Metro Tony on family as it stands
now will be an umbrella that will house
the GM lab the lab is literally called
the GM CMU connected an autonomous
driving collaborative research lab
that's quite a mouthful so I'm that
refer just a GM lab so the acronym that
views is actually cat crl connected or
autonomous driving collaborative
research lab so basically it has been a
relationship that literally dates back
18 consecutive years so it basically
says part of the family we house a
national university transportation
center on safety called technologies for
safe and efficient transportation it is
a national center safety is the primary
mission of the US Department Rance
petition we are a National Center on
this I should find Stan Cal well Stan oh
that is 10 hiding in a corner but doing
the work so sir stand I stand up so you
should take a bow as well so stan is the
executive director of tea set
and so that Awards in the process of
expiring am a multi-year grant meanwhile
we actually have traffic 21 Institute
which basically was really the outgrowth
that actually happened in 2009 when
Henry almond made his first grant to the
University to basically apply
technologies to basically mitigate
alleviate the problems that we all know
exists in Pittsburgh and beyond I should
bring up Professor Chris Hendrickson who
actually serves as the director standard
press and then asked the tea set UTC
grant is expiring we already have in
place a new national university
transportation center sponsored by the
USDOT call mobility 21 and that turns
out that strand defend up again he's the
executive director of that as well and
then last but not the least we have an
entity called the Metro Lab network yeah
used to be an integral part of CMU or at
least in my mindset
but right now it's actually an
independent 503 one C organization
nonprofit organization based in
Washington DC do I see Ben Levin Levine
Ben Schneider please so sub n is the
executive director of this entity based
in Washington DC it actually has a very
broad membership about 35 members of
cities around the country with each city
teaming up with a local research
university with the University acting as
a source of ideas and then cities acting
as the customers to basically consume
those ideas and Ben and his organization
bring together all these City University
members together on a regular basis to
identify propagate and adopt the best
practices that seem to work out there so
basically if we can get ideas to work in
Pittsburgh
Ben's organization connected became
campaign be a channel to basically
propagate it to the rest of the country
as well so that's kind of the the family
if you want so the extended family for
Metro 21 turns out to be the brand new
block center for technology and society
house then the Heinz College just
recently started with
very generous grant from Keith block and
alumnus of the Heinz College the Center
for the future of work also based in the
Heinz College led by professor Lee
Branstetter I guess one of the brain
children of Prosser Krishnan the
remaking cities Institute the College of
Fine Arts will have Don Carter coming in
later and we have a Steve quick out here
from the College of Fine Arts the Scott
Institute for energy innovation has been
a great partner and I could stand up and
take about two and as the executive
director of and that'll be they'll be
holding an energy week a couple of a few
weeks from now indirect the National
robotics engineering center based on the
I guess based in Lawrenceville and the
robotic Institute of ways out of which
indirect is based at they are very
strong partners with AI automation
robotics and such and then the smart
infrastructure Institute is been around
for many years from the brain children
of Dean Garrett so so this is kind of
the extended family too so it gives you
a sense for the the web of relationship
the via one on campus acting as a dual
ring so let's take a step back and look
at what metros or metropolitan regions
are about right so when you think of
metropolitan regions what do you think
about probably the first and foremost is
transportation I'm sure it's on Karina's
mind so congestion basically plays a
huge role in this our in you deciding
where you want to live and of course you
have to think about water water main
breaks and people immediately think
about it utilities like gas
telecommunications and the like Law &
Order law enforcement or healthcare and
dot dot dot basically air quality noise
quality light pollution there are
multiple dimensions that together
constitute life number two important
region right but actually look at those
entities out there they are consciously
being drawn as silos because each of
these dimensions that constitute
Metropolitan Life
really has been historically built
organized and operated as as a silo
independent xylem some of them are
private some of them are public
some of them are run out of public funds
taxpayers money some of them I guess are
pay-as-you-go right it's basically a
mishmash of various things right
what we would like to see Metro 21 do is
go from that set of independent silos so
to speak
can we actually have them all
interconnect interoperate and
communicate to basically become a
fine-tuned Swiss watch of you right now
let's take that analogy a little bit
further can we make that fine-tuned
Swiss watch into a smart device of some
kind where an ecosystem brings to you a
bunch of configurable applications that
can be customized to your individual
needs and preferences and because there
is an ecosystem people can add
applications in the future that you and
I cannot even imagine today okay that in
turn basically means that that needs to
be an infrastructure on the device and
infrastructure in the so-called cloud
out there on which creative people
innovators can come in and add new
applications and services some of them
may be free some of them may be paid for
right so that basically the idea can we
basically take this complex entity
called a city and then building
ecosystems and hooks in there so that
you at the end of the day can basically
use convenient devices at your disposal
customize it configure it for your
personal custom needs so that's
basically where we would like to go
right have these silos actually
communicate coordinate be optimized and
be extremely user friendly so this is a
view that Dean Garrett has been talking
about for quite some time as a city as a
smart city is really a system of
multiple systems these various silos
think of them as a system of its own but
it's really as a city is really a system
of systems so we need to worry about
mobility energy usage clean air and
water
and meanwhile economic prosperity the
grant was talking about all over smart
buildings and infrastructure and then
connected communities and such right so
basically so how do we create this
system of systems that is actually very
fun find here so clearly some building
blocks that will act as the bricks of
building a smart city here I literally
just friend laundry less transportation
digital infrastructure physical
infrastructure need to actually have a
communications backbone a wired or
wireless components within it sensing
and actuators for for example traffic
traffic lights transit Freight smart
streetlights and the like so basically
it gives you this physical framework
that could be able to sense and act upon
I guess that needs to be some notion of
a cloud computing you later on I heard
from Professor Satya from school of
computer science on edge computing bear
with me until then of course there will
be concerns about security and privacy
as well so that's not the kind of the
technical building blocks if you are but
one has to be very conscious and
cognizant of who the users are who the
use of groups are clearly citizens have
to benefit the residents of the city
have to benefit from a smart City
businesses want to be strictly be in a
smart city because they can run their
businesses efficiently effectively
profitably and in which in turn
basically it's convenient for the
residents employees actually want to
come into the city they get good jobs
and meanwhile you basically have the the
city workers who basically keep the
machine humming and you have to
basically think of all the communities
that we together behavior not an opah
person is an island so we work together
as a really friendly communities we need
to think about planners for example
Karina's should think both short term
and longer term if she runs from the
room you know that something has
happened out there that means should
take care of immediately but she also
has this long-term vision of using
treating see me as a partner and
basically getting a long-term solution
framework in place all right and then
meanwhile policymakers and the
decision-makers as well so basically
view think of basically the mayor the
county executive and vampire who can
basically trust this technology press
this policy frame you can say a building
a smart city is good for the city
overall
what are the pillars of metal 21 I'll
just point out three pillars we at Metro
Tony one will have an interdisciplinary
focus which we believe is actually a
considerable strength of Carnegie Mellon
where we will look at aspects that
impact people at the end of the day if
the people are not happy we would not
have succeeded technology for
technology's sake is a no-go like
technology to the into the benefit of
society to the benefit of the citizenry
is what we are after
policy is probably the barrier to
adoption of some what you would think as
being obvious technologies right policy
you have to be in place and the people
have to be on board right so this really
this interplay across people technology
and policy where we have this multiple
colleges all the way from hinds
engineering computer science Fine Arts
and so on all coming together along with
management to basically make things
happen so we believe that this
interdisciplinary fork is going to be
unique to Metro 21 and CMU this being an
institute and academic institution will
have at its core and intellectual
element we want to be scholars in the
domain work based on science not on
folklore and basically have an
educational mission as well the third
pillar would be we are looking to solve
real world problems there is no scarcity
of real-world problems with working yet
so the mantra that vehicle we put in
place dating back to 2009 with the
traffic 21 Institute is this notion of
not just doing R&D research and
development but doing our D&D which is
research development and deployment so
going back to the inter displayed for
goes all the way to taking those ideas
through scientific techniques and
knowledge building take it all the way
to deployment like you saw in that video
where basically have smart traffic
lights on the city the mayor of
Pittsburgh likes to brag about these
lights as the smartest traffic lights on
the planet you could look at Metro Tony
on two different ways one way of looking
at is that Metro 21 will serve as an
innovation engine
looking at a whole bunch of technical
attributes this slide is for the geeks
in the room okay so that's a whole bunch
of challenges of many different kinds I
guess a grant made this very important
point that if you try to maximize one
attribute called profits it may actually
end up minimizing another goodnight
rebuke meaning people's welfare and
wages so don't serve that building a
smart city is really about balancing
across multiple trade-offs between
mergers conflicts and so on and
therefore really certainly a
multi-dimensional optimization problem
okay so it turns out that you need to
bring to bear engineering technologies
policy innovations and then likely
basically bring together a smart city
the second way of looking at Metro 21
which is equally valid very
complimentary is that Metro 21 is
looking to serve as a change agent what
does that mean right we want to
basically for example build in literally
an ecosystem with tentacles all across
the metropolitan region which basically
brings in sensing information right
temperature humidity pressure light
noise air quality videos right
microphones audio odors streams and so
on they get processed which in turn I
going through for example a I of
different kinds smart traffic lights
being highlighted they're enabling true
mobility across the region being able to
share all these data across these
different silos that I mentioned earlier
and then meanwhile there has to be a
policy framework in place that basically
makes the the business model of the
operation be sustainable with
appropriate revenues and grant me this
point eloquently as well that the
benefits are equitable across the
resistance of the metropolitan region
right so there's basically the
innovation angle but an innovation by
itself is basically sits on a shelf we
need to be able to actually work with
partners like the city and the county to
basically transition that into a
practical love-filled environment with
the policy framework supporting it so
those are really two complementary
aspect along the process we do believe
that some of these innovation
we'll have to be translated into
day-to-day operation and support and
services just because it technology is
great it works and we understand the
policy framework that needs to be an
entity or an agency a likely supports an
ongoing basis so entrepreneurship will
play a role
so metal 21 with its family members as
over the time we'll know in term that is
launched multiple status startups
examples automatic are rapid flow
technologies and robotics so one of them
has already been acquired so we expect
to see many more spin-offs I think I can
imagine cities would want to wanting to
work with companies at the end of the
day for long term sustainability at the
core of Metro 21 will be Scholarship
refuel we being a non-academic entity we
will be looking at education education
not in the sense of just educating
students of campus me to actually raise
awareness of these technologies and
policies that work to make cities
smarter among government agencies and
various foundations and philanthropists
we to basically educate agency people
who basically operate and meanwhile need
they also educate companies about these
are new markets that they should be
targeting and they in turn kept
basically for example can converse with
the city side folks if you all the
municipalities and the corporations out
there to make things work so basically
so we will they can take on an education
mission in this realm we hope to build a
science of smart cities right it's not
just just engineering thumb gurus that
you fall all the time that's basically a
scientific body a scientific framework
behind it and say uh say a few more a
few more words about that very shortly
and there are clearly policy and
economic implications the greatest idea
in the world if it cannot be funded by
somebody will not take roots right so
basically in to basically have the
appropriate policy infrastructure that
they support it as well so let me talk
about the science of smart cities what
does the science of smart cities mean
think of the following how can we model
a city that we can analyze we can
characterize can we test a new power
see a new solution you're a new
interjection an interjection if you are
before taking on the cost and therefore
as implementing in practice and finding
that it does not work if you have a good
model you can test it the model if it
works well in the model maybe there are
good chances actually works in the real
world right so basically that model like
will play a big role do we know how that
solution that worked today will work
tomorrow when the population much larger
the city has grown larger can solutions
be characterized in a way that we can
generalize a solution to other
application domains to other cities can
we also for example say saying that take
this solution and say can i morph it so
that it work in transportation does it
work in water sewer management so you
want to be able to generalize or to be
able to network them with an appropriate
model can we so for example 15 20 years
from now can students or you correctly
walk into a library download an e-book
on the science of smart cities you have
a problem at hand you basically scan
through the book there's a formula set
of formulas you study it you understand
the concepts implemented bingo you're
done okay
can we do that right these are
challenges I'm not promising you
solutions tomorrow or the day after
tomorrow right but that's where you
would like to them let's run a simple
thought experiment right all species
living species have DNA we know that
right
cities have their own DNA correct and we
all know about genomes which basically
can sequence the genes that constitute
our DNA cellular infrastructure right we
have the genome so now can we model this
living breathing grow thing organism
called the city sequence its genome so
to speak identify the genes that make
the city tick or not tick how would
actually get deceased if Eva gets ill
and how can we recover from that
Richburg being a case in point used to
be a thriving city we went through a
depression in the 70s now we are seen as
a model of Renaissance
can we model that sequence if so if you
have that model in place we can inject
quote-unquote new genes modify the genes
and see what the end effect will be in
our modeling environment and then if it
works slip it in we can basically say
what happens if the species basically
grows from infancy childhood to
adulthood right so we think there are
grand research challenges to be
addressed I cannot think of a better
place and CMU where this can happen with
this true interpolation and now if you
think of this notion of sequencing a
genome you can imagine how I would allow
to basically being in our College of
Science into the mix because that's
where this work happens so they're
basically intellectual challenge to be
had so now let me give you a slightly
different perspective on how Metro 21
hopes to operate
so maybe with Metro 21 there is an
innovation activity I mentioned multiple
times today
basically we want to basically go
subterranean going Tom working process
Jean Van Driessen the College of
Engineering basically looking at for
example water sewage status health we
want so what actually go up wireless and
beyond all the way to the cloud virtual
where computations happen where
analytics happens with the huge amounts
of data that we that we collect so this
will be the innovation axis and
meanwhile that's a deployment axis where
VIP for example traffic renewing right
now is conducting a so-called smart
mobility challenge working with about
eleven municipalities around Pittsburgh
basically saying that your community
what kind of mobility challenges do we
have and then using traffic 21 fonts
basically researchers and campus have
engaged those communities basically
address real problems on the ground
right directly in the circus we are
expanding beyond Pittsburgh of course
and I guess on the other side it turns
out that we have been thinking of be the
bigger picture as well right now there
exists a coalition called the smart belt
coalition proposed by us at CMU this
marbella coalition is really
coalition of the states of Pennsylvania
Ohio and Michigan with the respective
Department of Transportation CMU in
Pennsylvania Ohio State University in
Ohio and the inertia of Michigan in Ann
Arbor
so again agencies and Eunice's working
together creating the smart belt
coalition this coalition name was very
conscious was very explicit remember the
age-old narrative that people have had
in the country about this being the
Midwest which is now referred to as the
Rust Belt we are looking to transform
that narrative we are no longer a spell
we have the smart belt that we apply new
technologies new policies new thinking
new paradigms to transform this okay so
if you are thinking broader and then of
course with Metro lab Ben's organization
you want to go nation nation national
and we are talking to global partners as
well stay tuned so basically is that
innovation access and a deployment taxes
so now let me I guess can I give you the
the big picture of you okay I'm towards
the end of my remarks when we say smart
cities you think urban right but this is
really about Metro 21 metropolitan
regions are really about I guess open at
the core perhaps but it's basically
suburban areas around the urban core and
then we also have rural communities
beyond this so basically we really like
to basically span communities across
urban suburban and rural areas we want
to be able to bring the innovation
access to play right automated vehicles
connected vehicles Internet of Things
sensing economic models policies and
regulations right so the technology
access and then on the right hand side
it's probably too small to read but
basically lists the long list of
entities and ages that we want to work
with the city governments the
municipalities that the counties that
the states right country's working with
foundations working with the private
sector and anbiya right so basically
what marries all this together to
basically to accomplish what to yield
better mobility solutions
safety air quality noise quality water
quality health care law enforcement and
the like both equitably and affordably
affordably to all residents of these
regions right comprising of urban
suburban and rural so the idea is that
if you live in a metropolitan region you
should have access to all these
requirements right equitably as well
right so I think in that very sense I
actually I found the grants remarks to
be extremely appealing and so let me
summarize so the Metro Tony want smart
cities Institute is looking to leverage
innovations in technology and policy and
their interplay to have a positive
impact on metropolitan societies we see
innovations as an enabler as a force of
good technology is not trying to take
jobs away technology is not trying to
make people's life miserable we want to
use technology and policy for the good
of society we are looking to solve
real-world problems
driven by an intellectual core of
scholarship education and knowledge
building and last but not the least
we're looking to develop a science of
smart cities right working with partners
out there when the government sector the
private sector and the nonprofit sector
ok so I would like to invite you to join
us on this journey to make our cities
much better places to live it thank you
thank you we do now have a break we have
a break until 11 o'clock well I guess
before if I get tied
I should have highlighted the fact that
Karen Lightman's Karen Picard take a
stand take a bow
so Karen Lightman is the executive
director of Metro 21 she has a very
impressive track record actually ran in
the sequence awesome on micro
electromechanical systems for about 20
years almost 15 years 1770 who's
counting okay so you actually show it
turns out to her she sees an alumnus of
CMU actually worked with
some of the pioneers in that domain ax
from CMU so we've brought her back in to
basically replicate that success so
thank you Kara for all the work that
you've been doing looking forward to
seeing good things happen in the future